All right, hi and welcome
to Robotics Today.
The My name is Luca Carlone.
And I'm excited to introduce
Dr. Raia Hadsell as our speaker
today.
Raia is the director of
robotics and DeepMind.
Her research focuses on the
challenge of continual learning
for AI agents and robots.
And she's proposed
popular approaches
such as quality distillation,
progressive nets,
and elastic reconsolidation
to solve the problem
of catastrophic forgetting.
Let me say that, Raia had
a quite unique career path.
After an undergraduate degree
in religion and philosophy
from Reed College, she started
to be interested in computer
science and ended up doing a
PhD with Yann LeCun at NYU,
focusing on machine
learning for robotics.
She knew also post-doc at
CMU working with Drew Bagnell
and Martial Hebert.
And then became a
research scientist
in the Vision and Robotics
Group at SRI International.
Finally, she joined
DeepMind in 2014
to pursue new solutions
for artificial general
intelligence.
Raia's Work is being
widely recognized.
Her thesis about Learning
Long-range Vision
for Off-road Robots was awarded
the Outstanding Dissertation
award in 2009.
She's on the executive
boards of ICLR,
Women in Machine
Learning, and CoRL.
She's a Fellow of the European
Lab on Learning System
and serves as a CIFAR advisor.
Raia, thanks for being here.
The stage is yours.
Thank you very much, Luca.
Looking forward to
giving the talk.
Thanks for the invitation
and for the introduction.
Let's see here.
I'm going to talk a
little bit about what
I think would be a few
different directions where
we could go to--
a little bit of a different way
to think about machine learning
and robotics.
But let me start first
with Deep Learning.
So as we all know
now, Deep Learning
is powerful because
we've got big data
and we've got these
wonderful architectures,
these Deep Learning
models that really scale
very well to fit the data set.
And there's always
sort of this notion
that we've got a lot of data
and we've got this big model.
And when the two scale
together, then we
can really achieve
impressive things.
This is well supported
by large-scale compute
and by end-to-end optimization.
Now, you can think about Deep
RL as looking a little bit
the same.
Sorry, microphone problems.
Again, we are thinking
about a certain balance
that we might imagine
between an agent
that we're training
and an environment
that we're learning in.
With the difference
being that, of course,
in Deep Reinforcement
Learning, then we're
thinking about the
agent is actually
generating its own
data sets that it's
learning from by taking
actions in the environment
and learning from the
observations that come back
in order to maximize
your reward.
So, yes, the agent
built it's own data set.
And with this sort of simple
view of it, in a lot of ways,
we've been able to come up with
a lot of interesting things.
We've been able to
optimize over behaviors
and discovered
things that are not
obvious and not easy
to directly encode,
such as behavior, of
course, of this agent that's
learning to play an Atari game.
And we can-- using the almost
exactly the same approach,
we can also see impressive
behaviors emerging when
we train an agent
to, for instance,
simply maximize its
forward velocity.
So this 56 dimensional
humanoid model
can be taught to
run across a terrain
and jump across gaps in
quite an impressive way.
This agent was optimized
for a very long time
until it could solve this
task really, really well.
And why does this work?
Again, because
we've got an agent
that is powerful enough that
it can fit to that environment
that we've given it.
It's essentially memorizing
the entire environment
is why it optimized it so well.
And this is impressive.
It's fun.
It's interesting.
But we want to go a
little bit beyond this.
We want to move AI research
beyond the simple picture
of having an agent
and an environment,
and where the agent can fully
fit to that environment.
Instead, I would
say that we want
to agents that are actually much
smaller than the environments
that they learn, such
that there's no hope
that that agent can actually
fit the whole environment.
Why would we want that?
Why would we want
agents that are dwarfed
by the size, the
complexity, or the richness
of the environment, such that
the capacity of the agent
is not sufficient to
model that environment?
Well, we want this--
it's important because it's
the driver of, I would argue,
many wonderful things that we
look for in our research that
should transfer.
So only by having an
agent that does not
have sufficient capacity to just
learn the entire environment,
only by having to that
imbalance balance do
we need to become
better at things
like transfer and generalization
and also fast adaptation.
If the environment
is small, the agents
can just learn the whole thing.
But instead, we can also
have continual learning.
There's no need for
continual learning
if you can observe the
entire environment,
you can learn at all.
But if we have this
imbalance, then
this can drive
continual learning,
can also drive causal reasoning.
Causal reasoning
comes from needing
to have more efficient
ways of understanding
the relationship and the
dynamics of environment that
can't come from simple--
from memorizing-- from
observing everything.
And abstract concepts.
So first question, how do we
make an environment complex?
What does that even mean?
Is an Atari environment complex?
Is a humanoid control
environment complex?
Well, we can think about it
in a few different dimensions
of complexity.
So first of all,
the observations
that an agent takes
in an environment,
real data has much
more complexity
than in a simulation.
So although, I use
simulation in my research,
I think that it's
important to recognize
the value of real data for the
noise and the complexity that
is expressed there.
There's also partial
observability.
So of course, if you can see
everything in an environment,
then it's definitely not
going to be as complex
as if I can only see through
a bit of a soda straw
or through a limited
view over time.
There's also multiple
sensory modalities.
So if there is not
only vision, but also
audio, touch information, et
cetera, in the environment,
then it will be more complex.
You can also look at the
dynamics of an environment.
Things like interaction and
contact having multiple agents.
This greatly multiplies
the complexity.
And then you can think
about the world itself.
So a lot of research
environments that we look at
or task environments for
training robots or agents
tend to be very short lived.
We think about maybe
in an environment
where we can perfectly reset
things and have episodes
that last very--
on the order of seconds.
Instead, we can think
about the length
of time of the life of
our agents, the experience
of the agents.
And we can think
about worlds that
are persistent where changes
made by one agent at one time
would persist through.
And those changes would be
evident to another agent
at another time.
All right, so let's turn
to how an agent can learn
in a very complex environments.
So one way is through learning
with multiple objectives.
So one way, I believe, to
deal with the fact of having
a lower capacity agent
and a more complex world
is to use multiple reinforcement
learning objectives
for instance, multiple rewards,
constraints, penalties.
There should be a
rich scope of things
that an agent is trying
to achieve in any given
environment.
There can also be--
of course, reward is not the
only way in which we can learn.
We can also include supervised
learning and unsupervised
learning, which is all
of the parts of the cake,
as my advisor would say--
former advisor would say.
Another approach is to learn
with many tasks or skills.
So rather than learning
a single skill,
such as running with
forward velocity
to the end of the track as that
humanoid was trained to do,
instead learning to do many
different things in one
environment is a
great way for an agent
to learn some of the
different notions of transfer,
of abstract concepts,
of causality, et cetera.
And then the last point
that I would make here
is that learning with
humans is something
that we could do more of to
enable agents to learn, even
in these more
complex environments.
And that can include
learning from demonstration
or learning through
imitation, for instance,
from the third
person perspective.
Simple observation, I
think that the agents that
can be taught just to
learn from observing others
in a complex world,
this can be valuable.
I think about this
every time I'm
out in the world
with other humans
and watching them and realizing,
I don't need to imitate them.
I learn through simply
observing what they do
and the outcomes
of their behaviors.
And through language as well.
So these are all sorts of
areas, this is very general.
But I just think
that these are--
that we as the
research community
is spending a lot of
time on optimizing
for smaller domain and
maybe simpler approaches,
when really we need to embrace
the complexity of agents
as well as the environments
that they learn.
So let me present a
couple of research results
that we've had
recently at DeepMind.
So the first one--
and both of these methods
are about imitation.
But imitation used in
very different ways.
So imitation can be used as
a source of data as a way
to learn the fundamentals
movement, the fundamentals
of control.
Or it can be used as sort of the
other end of learning in order
to give a demonstration
or to demonstrate
a task that needs to be done.
So I like to think about
these two different sides
of using expert data.
One at the beginning to
learn representations.
And one at the end
to demonstrate goals.
So the first work is
about using mimicry
to learn basic motor control.
All right, so why do we want
to learn reusable skills?
Well, learning from scratch
can be data efficient.
I'm just showing here this old
parkour video that probably
people have seen before.
The internet seemed
to like this video.
And this showed some
impressively robust control,
behavior and skills.
But we do end up in a regime
where this is data inefficient
and where we don't have
a lot of constraint
of the behavior of
the agent over time.
So exploration is limited
and transfer is limited.
So how can we learn
reusable skills?
Well, we could-- there are
unsupervised skill discovery
methods.
You could learn from
a lot of simple tasks.
For instance, via
the method called
scheduled auxiliary control.
Or you could use
demonstrations, which
is what this work is based on.
Or specifically
do joint training
with tasks and demonstrations.
So let me start by mentioning
neural probabilistic motor
primitives, or
otherwise called NPMP.
And the idea here is to train
an expert policy by tracking
kinematic motion capture clip.
And then to force
the policy to be
bottlenecked through a latent
layer that can then be reused.
So basically,
we're going to take
some set of clips here of
different types of human motion
coming from human
motion capture.
And we're going to
learn to predict--
we're going to learn to
encode the future state.
Go through a latent state,
which we can interpret
as being a latent intention.
And that's going to then
go to a decoder, which
will produce an action.
We also feed in
the present state
the proprioception
of the current robot.
And the output action
tries to imitate
the next state of these clips.
So basically, we're
trying to learn
to follow each of these over
time by controlling a human--
by controlling a
humanoid figure.
And the key thing is that
this latent intention
is used to develop this
latent embedding Zt.
We can then reuse
exactly the same decoder.
Now we've learned how to go
from an input in the state
in the embedding Zt--
we've learned to go from
that directly to action.
So now this becomes
the action space.
And we can learn a task policy
that's going to control this.
So now given an RL
environment, given
some tasks that we
want to do from reward,
then we can reuse the decoder
as a low-level skill module.
So we're going to take an
observation from this task
space, whatever that
is, and then we're
going to learn how to create
an action in that space.
It's not necessarily a
lower dimensional space.
In this case, the action
space, 56 dimensional
and the embedding space
the 60 dimensional.
But that embedding
space, at least,
has within it all of the
different types of motion
that we might expect a
humanoid character to do.
Does not have a lot of
laying on the ground
and flailing around because
that set of expert clips
does not contain that
type of behavior.
Instead, it has productive
movement locomotion,
sitting, turning, standing,
jumping, et cetera.
So this is a really
nice and efficient way
of learning low-level
motor behavior
and then being able to use it
for reinforcement learning.
So the work in
this paper in comic
instead says, this is a
little bit inefficient
to do these things in
two separate spaces.
Let's instead put
it all together
into one RL environment.
So now we're going to
take these both together,
we're going to say, I'm going
to take these expert clips
and I'm going to
try to imitate them.
And I'm also going
to take observations
from tasks that I'm
learning at the same time.
For instance, go through
this obstacle course.
And I'm going to
push both these--
I'm going to learn to use Z. At
the same time, this embedding
space as a latent
intention space, which
tries to do imitation.
And also as a
high-level action space
to fulfill my task policy.
And I'm going to reward
both the imitation
and I'm going to reward the task
using quite different rewards.
One is a reward that
comes from following
each joint position of the mocap
data we're trying to track.
And the other one is a
fresh reward from velocity.
So the research
questions that come--
we sort of got us
working together,
the two different parts.
Put them together
and said, let's just
train the whole thing at
the same time, co-training
and mimicry.
But then we wanted
to say, well, how
do the different architectures
we could use compare here?
How do they compare in terms
of the tracking performance?
How do they compare in
terms of reusability?
And how well does the joint
training approach work?
So in order to evaluate
this, we use a motion
capture data set from CMU--
from the CMU motion
capture data set
and the humanoid
model, like I said,
with 56 degrees of freedom.
And in each episode, we
sample a starting point
from a lot of different clips.
And use a reward similar
to the DeepMimic paper
where we have terms
that are weighted
to match different
positions to interpretation.
We trained this using
on-policy Rl using V-MPO.
The links are there
for more information
about these
different approaches.
And using KL regularization
of the skill embedding space--
just that latent space,
which is important to make
this work well.
And then we tried out
some different low-level
architectures.
So how do we want to
have that decoder--
that action decoder that
becomes the motor module?
How do we want to--
and how do we want
to represent that?
So I looked at an MLP.
We looked at LSTM.
Mixture of Gaussians or
product of Gaussians.
But states which have
all been used in previous
works with different success.
We just wanted to
compare against these.
And then so we can look
at different motion
capture data sets and
how they are valuable.
So there are two small ones.
One with just walking,
one with just running,
one that has more
larger locomotion.
A lot of different clips there
something up to 40 minutes
of data.
And then we have
a large sort of--
larger set of clips that has
much longer sequences in it
and a lot more motion, which
is 3 and 1/2 hours long.
For the transfer for
the joint training,
then we looked at a
couple of different tasks.
First, we have a go
to go to dot task--
go to target task.
And then two different
parkour type of tasks,
where the humanoid needs
to traverse gaps or wall
obstacles.
These tasks have a dense
reward and they have
egocentric visual observations.
So these aren't done
from state information,
because they're actually
done from visual information.
The proprioception
is available as well.
And we also specifically
looked at a couple of tasks
that we knew were
not represented
in the data of the
original data set.
So being able to get
up from laying down
is something that's not
present in the motion capture
data sets.
So we knew that this
is something that would
need to be learned separately.
And the other one was catching
an object, which is not
represented in the data set.
So when we look at just learning
the tracking performance,
learning to track the
motion capture data
set, then we can see that the
best architecture is the LSTM.
So this performs well across all
of the different data regimes
whether or not we have
a small amount of data
or the very largest set.
The MLP also performed
well in all settings.
Take a look at this
tracking performance
that is learned in
joint with the task.
And if we just look at
the tracking performance,
this is the largest data set.
And we can imitate various
walking and running behaviors.
So the character in silver
is the human motion capture,
and the one in gold is the one
that the agent is controlling.
And probably you saw
that little glitch there
where it just
decides, I'm not going
to try to do that
fancy spin that's
done in motion capture data.
And the agent sort of skips past
that quite opportunistically.
But in general, we see
that all of the behaviors
can be robustly followed,
including walking backwards,
dancing, et cetera.
Now, if we look at transfer.
So here we have
transfer to the go
to target task, the walls
task, and the gaps task.
Starting with
low-level controllers
that are trained on either
the walking, running,
the locomotion of
large data set.
And we see that
all of these cases,
even though the LSTM did the
best in the actual tracking
test, then it's the MLP
that does decidedly better.
And this worked across--
the MLP works across almost
every one of the tests
that we did for that transfer.
The LSTM low-level
policies are probably
less reliant on the
embedding space.
They're probably memorizing
the data a little bit more,
whereas the MLP is forced
to stay a little bit more
tied, a little bit more
reliant on the embedding space.
So it's going to do
better for transfer.
Here's a video showing
one of the models
traverse an obstacle
course with gaps.
This train simultaneously
with the agent.
So the gaps task is not
present in the training regime.
And it does do quite
well on the training.
Let's take a look one more time.
Now compared with the original
parkour agents that I showed
you that is galloping
across this gaps task,
this agent does not
do quite as well.
That's because it's actually
constrained by the latent
space.
Now, training on this task is no
longer training all the way end
to end.
But instead, the training
stops at the latent embedding.
And therefore, you don't get
quite that full optimization
that you get if you only train
for this task from scratch.
On the other hand,
this was able to be
trained in a matter of
minutes rather than days.
And it uses a bit less energy.
And in terms of the--
we look at the actions
that are taken, and is
a bit more constrained in
terms of what it learns.
So we see this transfer
as being important,
even though it doesn't get
to quite the same performance
as the original parkour agent
that can run through very
quickly.
I think I'm going to move on
to the next piece of research
that I wanted to talk about.
There's more details in
this paper, which I would
encourage people to look at.
There's a longer
video and website
that shows more of the results,
some of the co-training
reports that I'm not
going to go into here.
So as I said, there
are different ways
to use expert data.
One way in which
I just showed is
to use expert data
as a starting point.
Expert data has a
way to quickly--
more efficiently get to a
low-level representation
that has been more reusable.
The other way in which we
would want to use demonstration
for robotics is to use it as
the end point to give a targets.
To demonstrate a task and then
being able to quickly execute
that task.
So that's what this
next book focuses on.
The title of this is
Manipulator-Independent
Representation Learning
for Visual Imitation.
So the work focuses on
third-person imitation
for robotics manipulation.
And the challenge here
is imitation from pixels.
So this video-- this
sort of crude rendering
shows a teleoperation
that we might
want to do where we
demonstrate moving a block
and stacking it on
top of another block.
What we would like to do is
be able to take something
from this simple
information that's shown
and be able to replicate
this with a real robot
in the real world.
Or even better, being able
to demonstrate something
like this with a human hand and
then repeat it with a robot.
And it's important to say
that we want to be able to--
we don't want to have to use
the teleoperation of the robot
directly but be able to
do this imitation just
from third-person imitation.
So not have task rewards,
not have proprioception,
not have action.
But simply have
the visual system
and be able to
imitate from that.
And the challenge is, of course,
that we have this domain gap,
we have sort of in simulation,
things that look one way.
And then in the real
world, then things
are going to look
quite different.
Or we could have human
hands, we could have grippers
that could move things around.
And so we really need to learn
at extreme levels of invariance
or robustness if we want
to be able to imitate
from this type of demonstration.
So the approach here--
I will point to this figure
here where what we see
is a hand that is demonstrating
a stacking of one block on top
of another block.
Human is here doing that.
And we want to send the sort of
first way points along the way.
We want to send that through
an encoder to a representation
space-- to a feature space.
And then use that as a
goal for an imitating agent
to be able to follow
the same action.
There are related
works in this area.
So here is the imitation and
NPMP work that we just showed.
And there's lots of
other work that's
been done in demonstrating
imitation learning.
A lot of this happens in
model-dependent state space,
and often for locomotion.
Existing approaches from
pixels are often applied
in the same domain, or where
there's a really limited domain
gap.
Or requires manually
labeled data, for instance,
doing post-extraction.
So the approach
that we have here
is to focus on
the representation
needed in order to do this
third-person visual imitation.
So the main properties of the
feature space we would like
is that we would like to be able
to do cross domain alignment.
So when we go from a real
robot to a simulated robot
or a real arm--
a human arm to a robot
arm, from one type of robot
to another type
of robot, we want
to be able to align those
different domain trajectories.
We want the feature space to
exhibit temporal movement.
And we want there to be
actionable representations,
meaning that the information
in that feature space
is sufficient that
we can take action--
the agent can take
actions with respect
to that, which means
embedding the actions in that
[INAUDIBLE].
So we use the fact that we have
simulation, we have access to--
in simulation to being able to
produce a high degree of domain
randomization.
But moreover, we can not
only randomize the domain,
we can also remove
the arm entirely.
And you can still see
here that the block--
one block is being stacked
on top of another block
even though the arm is
invisible all together.
This is just because
they're choosing
not to render that in this.
But we can have these
aligned trajectories.
We can also align
trajectories where
we randomize the entire domain
and where we randomized just
the visual features of the arm.
So the difference is these
different randomized domains,
randomized arms,
an invisible arms
are used in order
to build a data
set of aligned trajectories.
And from there,
trained our encoder.
In order to train the encoder
from this data set, aligned
trajectory then we
use a variant of TCN,
which is temporal
contrastive network--
time contrastive
network, which we
call simple smooth
contrastive network.
And we train goal condition
policies across the domains.
So we want to be able to
pair trajectories and learn
the right-- learn
the action that
was taken in either case
across these different domains.
And then we can train to get
to the next goal position
from the current observation
using reinforcement learning.
All right, so here,
we look a little bit
into that feature space to
see how the distances are
in the embedded space.
So we can take a robot
arm at the first time step
and compare it to a human
hand moving through a given
motion over 200 time steps.
And we can look at the
distances between looking
at cross domain case or
in the same domain case.
And what we hope to see
here is that the method
will have a relatively
smooth, well-behaved distance
measure across this as it goes
from unaligned to more aligned
over time.
So this is looking at
time contrastive network,
just looking at temporarily
smooth contrastive network.
This is the manipulation
and variant representation.
And then this is cross domain--
I've forgotten what the GCP is--
the generative
contrastive policy.
And it's basically, these
two are both ablations
of the last one, manipulation
and variance representation.
And so you can see
that this offers
a very nice smooth distance
measure in the same domain,
and also offers a relatively
smooth and accurate distance
measure, even when we're
looking cross domain
between the human
hand and a robot arm,
which has not been trained for.
So the goal is given
by different way points
every time the video
pauses here, showing
that in the human hand video.
Then we're giving a
new goal to the agent.
And we see that then
the agent, which is this
is the view that
it sees visually,
and then that's
the larger picture.
It's just another rendering.
And we can see it following
through the same part.
It goes to pick
up the red block,
then it hovers over
the blue block,
and then places it
down and releases it
at the same time
that the human hand--
as it does this.
So obviously, the
environment has
been trained on different types
of blocks, different types
of stacking and moving around.
But note that there is
no actual reward here
that's coming from
the task of stacking.
The only reward is coming
from trying to get to a--
get to the goal
points that are given
in the video of the human hand.
And no human hands were ever
seen during the actual training
sequence at all.
It was purely trained on--
where in the three
cases where we
have the randomized arm,
the randomized environment
and where we have
been invisible arm.
So that's given us a
level of invariance
in the representation
that allows
us to then match the human hand,
which hasn't been seen before.
And just to give a couple
more examples here.
On the left, we see
tracking from a--
the real robot is
shown on the top.
And on the bottom, the
robot is shown in simulation
and is stacking, again, the
red block on top of the blue.
This was used just
for test purposes.
The middle view, we
show that the goal
is being given--
the demonstration is
being given using a Pick-up
Stick, but by a human.
But we just see the stick.
And again, the agent
is able to follow that
and match that trajectory
and stack the block.
And in the last view, then
we're using a different robot
arm and simulation.
So this demonstrating the
following a different robot--
the different robot
arm-- the Jaco hand
at the top and a robotic
gripper simulated at the bottom.
All right, next, I just have a
couple of quantitative results.
We really tried to look at
this carefully and understand
what the benefits were of
this manipulator and varying
representation.
So we looked at lifting
success and stacking success
across having different
types of representations
and different types of transfer.
And in each of these cases,
the most successful case
is using the manipulation
and variant representation.
All right, so I find this
to be a nice result that
shows that one can use
simulation in a pretty
simple way to
achieve really pretty
significant invariance
over different types
of representation.
And this has allowed
us to have agents
that can track relatively
easily how to move blocks around
in this environment.
Even using demonstrations from
a human from a different point
of view with all of the demoing
gaps, of course, that are here.
One of the key things
was in training,
representation was
temporally smooth
and allowed us to,
like I said, achieve
a level of robustness
that is a good start
for third-person
visual imitation.
All right, these are the
two papers that I presented.
The second one's on archive.
The first one was
from ICML last year.
Please, take a look
at those if you have--
and contact the office here
if any further questions.
Thanks a lot.
Thanks a lot, Raia,
for your great talk.
Thank you for your time and
for going into these two papers
really in depth.
So before we get started--
so basically, the
panel and the audience
have many questions that
we can't wait to discuss.
And before we get
started, I just
wanted to mention to
the remote audience
that we do have a way
for you to ask questions.
So if you go to our website
page and to the livestream
and you scroll down, you
see a slideshow interface.
There are already
a few questions.
You can also just upload them
instead of asking your own.
And our student panel, Krishnan
[INAUDIBLE] and Marion Lepert,
will pick up your
posted questions
during the discussion.
But before we go
to your questions,
I would like to introduce
today's guest panelists.
And first, I welcome
Chelsea Finn,
who is assistant professor at
the Computer Science Department
at Stanford University.
And I also welcome
Pulkit Agrawal,
who is assistant professor
in the Department
of Electrical Engineering
and Computer Science at MIT.
And Chelsea, I was
wondering if you
can go first with any
questions you have for Raia?
Yeah so I had one
lower-level comment
and one higher-level comment.
Or question, not comment.
So for the second work,
it looked quite cool.
And I was wondering,
since it's often not
too hard to define a reward
function in simulation,
I'm curious if you compared
to a setting where you did
have rewards in simulation
instead of having human videos?
Or if you have hypotheses
about how they might compare?
Yeah, good question.
It's true that we
can easily evaluate
this in the simulation.
And we can have those rewards.
And we can also look at them
on the real robot as well.
In simulation, we did--
so for these sets of objects,
we're able to get to--
with quite a bit of training on
that specific task of stacking,
we are able to get to
about 75% stacking success
on the lifting,
grasping, stacking.
But it does come with
the cost of having
a reward that has to be--
that needs to be shaped in
pieces, learning to pick up,
learning to stack and
learning whether to stack red
on blue or blue and red, sort of
make it conditional, et cetera.
So this work really
did come out of saying,
this is not a sustainable way.
We need to sort of escape from
the requirements of building
the--
of having more and
more complex task
come with these insurmountable
rewards that need to be fine--
need to be tuned and
trained on, et cetera.
So this agent can get
to, I'd say about,
half of that success.
But without any customized
reward or training
for the task at all.
Great.
Yeah, that makes a lot of sense.
And then my second
question at a high level
is, at the beginning, you
argued that agents should
be smaller than
their environments,
such that the complexity
and richness exceeds
the capacity of the agents
ability to model it.
And so I'm curious what you
think about large language
models, which show that--
we show that basically, if
you do scale neural networks,
it does seem like they can
model considerable degrees
of complexity of real data.
Do you think that
robotics data is
more complex than the language
data that these are modeling?
Do you kind of agree
with that approach
or do you think that
we're ultimately going
to need different approaches?
It's a good question.
I wish that there
was a equivalent
source of natural data that
could be used for robotic.
Probably the closest
thing is YouTube
in terms of having large
sources of natural data
that have that same level of
diversity and sort of breadth.
But I don't think that
we have a straightforward
way of learning robotics from
that type that type of data.
But, yes, I think that GPG3
is making a lot of people,
including roboticists,
think about how
we can get to that
level of data collection
and use so that we can train
models in that much more scaled
up sort of way.
Yeah, thank you very
much, Chelsea and Raia,
for your questions.
Pulkit, do you maybe have
one question for Raia?
Yeah.
Thanks, Raia, for the talk.
It was a very good talk.
So one question I have
is on the second part
that you were talking
about manipulator video
representation.
So if for the moment I put on
my computer vision [INAUDIBLE],,
it seems like if he had object
representations or segmentation
of objects, that
would really help
us be manipulator invariant.
But in the learning
community, we
try to learn representations
from scratch for every task
that we do.
And the reason is that
segmentation methods
don't end up working that
well when we transfer them
to our robotic tasks.
So I'm wondering you know what's
your perspective going forward.
I mean, should we
keep on learning
doing representation learning?
Or maybe try to see how we could
leverage learned segmentation
models or knowledge we
collect from previous tasks
so that we don't have to learn
representations for new tasks?
Yeah, thanks for the
question, Pulkit.
I think that it is a really
important question how
we bring together computer
vision models, representation
learning for the
purpose of robotics.
It's not clear that it's going
to be sufficient to train
in the sort of bespoke way.
We need to be able to, again,
look at much wider sources
and data, such as I
would say YouTube again
or similar type of scope and
be able to use that directly.
On the other hand,
simulation does give us
a tremendous amount
of power in being
able to generate
things very easily
and learn in a very
straightforward way.
I mean, I think this is
a lot of exciting work
to be done in this area.
Yeah, with that,
I'm afraid we have
to close a little early today.
And we will look
at your questions,
and maybe come back to them.
Thank you very much for
coming today, everyone.